eu sou gay a se casar com o nome
tenho dois filhos maravilhosos que foram
criados graças a duas mulheres que não
jogaram lá na califórnia a gerar seus
filhos
estou muito orgulhoso da minha família é
muito grave com essas mulheres que nos
ajudaram a fazer esse sonho realidade é
criar essa família
dois meses atrás o nosso filho tancredi
o maior de 11 anos foi diagnosticada com
uma mina explodiu na leucemia
isso é a vida dele em risco mas nem
todas as mais se pais que esteja aqui
como nós nos sentimos como um medo de
perder uma sua filha e nós temos duas
opções temos afundar chorar ou resolver
lutar e acreditar fé força e continuar
procurando na medula óssea para achar
para ele conseguir fazer um transplante
de medula aquilo que ele precisa passem
curado e aí foi muito incrível porque
todas as mais da escola e todas mais
amigas nossas fizeram todo um movimento
muito grande divulgando na imprensa e
nas redes sociais por todo lugar levando
as pessoas doar sangue é doar medula
muito incrível foi um momento muito
lindo e todo esse movimento nos fez
pensar fez que o tancredo através dessa
doença nos transmitiu uma mensagem muito
importante para todos nós
primeiro para nós e depois para todo o
resto do mundo
a primeira mensagem foi que quando um
filho até leucemia e também fica de vida
todos o resto dos problemas de medos e
preocupações
não importa todo mas não tem relevância
realmente importa
isso nós aprendermos essa lição e se
espalhou para os amigos para as mães da
escola para a sociedade as pessoas no
facebook falando a verdade não importa
que ele probleminha que eu tinha
importa mais o mais importante é a vida
à luta pela vida e pelo amor
a segunda mensagem que ele passou com
essa doença assim pública com esse
movimento
achar um doador foi que as pessoas nos
viram como uma família homossexual
homoparental na família que se ama que
se acolhe que é igual o que torna estas
famílias porque no fundo não importa que
sejam os dois homens ou duas mulheres um
pai de uma mais prazer na família um pai
vivo ou uma mais divorciada guerreira
o importante é o amor da família essa
união esse é o que dá força e só que da
vida e é isso que vai salvar a vida do
meu filho
o terceiro mensagem muito importante que
o tranqüilo passou com essa doença para
o mundo e que minha sangue minha medula
óssea
nós podemos fabricar elas nossa fábrica
sales o torcedor sou humano para doar
para outro humano se levar o tancredo
levantou essa consciência
nós temos essa capacidade de doar sangue
para quem precisa e sabe nós só para
alguém que tem casa no sangue
você precisa nos partos quando temos um
acidente enquanto o momento todos os
bancos de sangue precisa doar medula
óssea se cadastrar como doador de medula
óssea a chance de compatibilidade entre
um doador eo paciente é de 11 sobre semi
pessoas
então se você pode salvar a vida é como
se enganar se a mega senha da vida você
pode falar na vida você pode ser um
herói
eu quando me cadastrar e para mim foi um
momento muito lindo de poder esperando
que eles me chamarem para que eu possa
salvar na vida se me esforce animador
estou doando uma parte de mim para poder
salvar na minha gestão é coisa mais
linda ea mensagem que o tancredo espaço
a todos nós
eu agradeço a todos vocês e vamos apoiar
por essa união que não estamos sentindo
esse apoio incondicional não só para
salvar a vida de tancredo
mas para ter essa consciência que nós
todos podemos doar sangue é doar medula
para salvar vidas e ser super heróis
obrigado